so we did the phoenix rising project for
1.5 million dollars
the
floor plans were 280 square foot studio
a 340 square foot one bedroom all made
in our factory we shipped it there
um for i think about 125 or 150 a door
which is how yep 125 a door people can
work out their own uh price per square
foot which i know you know you're
reticent to talk about um let's talk
about who this was built for who's
living in these and the impact it's
having on that community
and then let's talk about the build
quality
of these because the thing that i was
amazed that when i visited the factory
uh which with mitch kapoor uh who's also
on the board an investor in the company
was just the the
the quality of the build and what you
were able to do in terms of
um
energy efficiency and higher quality so
start with either one who's living there
or the quality level and what
innovations we had in that version of
blocks
yeah i think that so a lot of it with um
with the phoenix rising project was
honestly if we were not a vertically
integrated developer the project just
never would have happened because a lot
of a lot of the you know you were sort
of alluding to it at the beginning
you know
the way that the market works both for
affordable and market rate um
is very complicated so there's a lot of
complication as to like how something
goes from being you know a piece of land
that on which it's legal for you to
build something to having something
completed that people are paying to live
in and how they pay for it
so for instance for the phoenix rising
project
if we were
a traditional developer so traditional
not-for-profit housing is developed
usually developed through low-income tax
credits right so low income tax credits
legally the only way that you can you
can go out and submit an rfp to build
something if you're a modular builder
you're you have to legally sell your
product to a partnership that includes
an architect the general contractor and
a developer so that's how it's set up so
the state state of washington had
allocated some money that they wanted to
try some different things with they
called it their innovative housing fund
and they had allocated a small amount of
money and they said we want to go try
something different
if they had put that out to tender if
they had just said we're going to give
this up to the county the county's going
to put out an rfp we would never be able
to apply for that because we're not
under the umbrella of an architect
general contractor which means you know
we just wouldn't do it that way so we
had to work with uh the senator to have
the money uh funneled through a direct
appropriation so we said to the senator
we need you to say that this money is
going to be appropriated for this
specific project if you can do that then
legally the money is attached to that
project then we needed to provide the
contract structure so that the
not-for-profit who owned the site that
was legal to build on
could contract us to deliver it as a
design build vertically integrated
modular developer basically was you know
we gave them a cost and a schedule and
all the risk was on us we said look
we're going to deliver to you at this
price on this schedule you're taking no
risk in this you're going to draw down
the money from the state when you draw
it down from the state you're going to
pay us that's the nature of the contract
so it's it's
really difficult to actually find sites
if you're developing a new building
system or a new product and you're going
through these rounds of prototyping one
of the most challenging aspects is to
actually be able to find sites that you
can build on
because traditionally
if you have a factory
it's not a pro all kinds of developers
will come to you and say if you can
build it for me for this cost i'll give
you a 200 unit project to go build right
and then you've got to go figure it out
and then you actually don't develop that
much product innovation because the
project's too big and in the end you
probably do some framing and that's
enough innovation at that stage and then
you're locked into that because that's
what the market wants you to build
so the phoenix rising project
was a huge success in that
we pushed it through from both a
regulatory and a finance perspective
which was probably the more difficult
aspect of what we did so the people who
are living there
um uh
phoenix rising is run by a group called
valley cities and valley cities is a
not-for-profit that operates in puget
sound area and they are generally a
behavioral health not-for-profit so that
um that site has on it basically a
shelter so it's a shelter for youth who
have substance abuse or other types of
of issues
they can only have people in that
shelter up to a certain age and then
they were finding that once those people
got to that age there was nowhere in the
market for them to go live so a lot of
them would end up on the streets or end
up you know some other situation
so the
housing ended up being for people who
earn less than 30 percent of area median
income which in that area i think is
somewhere between
17 and a half and 20 000 a year right
income oh wow yep and so and a lot of
these folks were literally homeless
which means that they did not have homes
prior to them moving into into the
phoenix rising project
so
on the one side of it you're taking a
really difficult problem in society
right which is people who make some
money but there's just really nowhere
that they can afford to live and they
often oftentimes need supportive
services around that as well where they
might need to get back on their feet
they need to get job counseling services
or they need to get access to different
things so there was there was one woman
whose story has been coming out more and
more who's been living in one of these
studio units and it's literally right
across the street from a school
and it turns out her kid goes to the
school across the street but she had
been homeless for a period of time and
during that period she lost custody
rights of her kids so her kids weren't
able to visit her so she moves into this
new apartment and this new apartment is
like head and shoulders higher quality
than anything else not only anything
else that's subsidized but anything else
in the neighborhood at all like the
housing around there is really you know
it's it's not long-term housing
it's typical
so she moves into this beautiful
apartment and then she starts talking
about how she's now able to get back on
her feet so she's got visitation rights
with her kids again they can come see
her she's got access she's got a steady
address she's getting mail now she can
get visited she's got her income coming
in and like to her
the apartment is what turned her life
around because now she's able and so
this is this is what we've seen with
these apartments you know now that we're
eight months ten months into running
them one
people are keeping them in incredible
condition so these are clean
they're beautiful
and it's it's actually taken a community
where there's a lot of you know sort of
sketchy stuff going on and now there's
lights on on the exterior there's people
living there and so the whole area has
become safer
the people are keeping their units in
beautiful condition because they have a
lot of respect for the the place that
they're living in and what it's done for
their lives
and then on the quality side
we're seeing that their the studios are
46 percent cheaper to operate based on
utilities and heating and cooling and
the one bedrooms are 60 lower cost to
heat and cool and that was a major
initiative during the build so when you
came to see the buildings in the factory
um
they were i think to a certain level of
finish they weren't done yet but they
were they were on their way but you
could see
you know in the factory uh they were
16th of an inch you know tolerance all
the way down the line so you could shoot
a laser through a hole in one of the
beams and get to the other end of the
factory
and then through our work with the
national renewable energy lab one of our
major areas of focus was
to really push how far we could get the
building performance in terms of its
energy efficiency
right because you can there's a lot of
effort going into
you know new batteries and new solar
panels and all kinds of new ways to
degenerate and create more energy
efficiency in housing
but the issue is
unless the building envelope is
efficient it's just going to be more
costly for everything else if you can
make the building envelope itself
efficient it takes a lot less energy to
power it it takes a lot less cost
and that's where being as the developer
on our larger projects which we're now
moving into the phase to go build
hundred-plus unit uh multi-family
projects as an owner
that all
that all comes back to your net
operating income so if you can operate a
building that that is 20 30 50 lower
cost to heat and cool that all comes
right back to the bottom line of the
real estate
we all know how hard it is to eat
healthy when you're grinding on your
product and you're trying to meet your
deadlines well now there's an innovative
food company trying to help real good
foods is one of the fastest growing
frozen food brands in the united states
they're making nutritious food more
accessible to improve human health and
they make the food you love mexican
italian breakfast sandwiches pizza all
that great stuff and everything is 100
grain free low in carbs and high in
protein and the best part it's made from
real food ingredients they're available
in your freezer section at costco
walmart target and 90 of grocery stores
nationwide plus you can get them
delivered same day via instacart real
good foods is healthy convenient and
tasty it's perfect for any lifestyle
plus part of their mission is to support
food banks across the united states and
they have a goal of donating one million
nutritious meals so you'll feel good
about buying go to realgoodfoods.com
and use the code twist to get 15 off
learn more and follow at real good foods
on social or go to realgoodfoods.com
right now okay welcome to the family